ich sollte es unbedingt mal wieder üben
aber ich konnte mich kann auch bietet
was geht ab netz bekommen zu einem neuen
video und zwar wollte ich eigentlich für
heute mit meinem bruder an ein video
drehen jetzt leider verhindert also geht
nicht und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht
komm mach doch mal
ich mein ich habe jetzt ich habe ganz zu
anfang vor eineinhalb jahren oder so mal
hier so einen 15 fakten über mich
gemacht und ja das ist jetzt schon
ziemlich lange her und es sind auch ganz
ganz viele neue dazu kommt ab 100 warum
machst du nicht einfach mal so ein 30
fakten über dich oder 35 oder 40 keine
arme hat jetzt werde ich später merkt
deswegen york viel spaß mit dem video
gibt ein paar fakten zu mir ich habe mir
das auch gut und falls euch gefällt ist
auf jeden fall noch nach oben und bürger
viel spaß
ich würde mal sagen gefangenen mit dem
wichtigsten effekt direktwahl am anfang
an und zwar lautet der
ich heiße alexa und der zweite effekt
wer dann ich bin 17 jahre alt und der
dritte effekt werden auch schon ich gehe
in die elfte stufe elfte klasse echte
stufe ist bei uns halt gymnasiums stufe
also ich gehe aufs gymnasium es wird
schon viel taktik alles passt jetzt so
zusammen diesen kanal besitze ich seit
ungefähr eineinhalb jahre also ich mache
ihn so seit eineinhalb jahren aktiv sage
ich mal
und ja ich habe in der zeit über 50.000
abonnenten erreicht jetzt schon und das
ist mega castro man danke dafür
wir haben vor zwei wochen also 50.000
erreicht und jetzt ins bald schon viel
15.000 oder ebenso unser dankeschön der
nächste effekt ist glaube ich ihr ganz
wichtig und zwar fragen jetzt auch immer
sehr viele leute warum heißt einen kanal
blockbuster ich hatte auch schon
irgendwann beantwortet glaube ich auf
jeden fall ist das so im fernsehen läuft
ja immer dieser blockbuster da hab ich
mir gedacht ich hatte mal einen alten
kanal da kommen jetzt noch zu und
einfach hier locken werde ich so ein
bisschen deswegen einfach dass die lok
durch locker setzt daraus ja und ich
weiß der name blockbuster passt
eigentlich nicht ganz so gut auf meine
jetzigen kanal aber ich hatte halt schon
mal den kanal
da hatte ich dann 3000 abonnenten haben
nie aufgehört und den gelöscht und
deswegen das passte damals auf den kanal
zu und/oder traf darauf zu holen jetzt
zwar nicht mehr so aber ich habe den
damen einfach beibehalten ich habe mein
erstes youtube-video also wirklich so
vor der kamera mit 14 gedreht ist mir
mal so aufgefallen das ist echt cool
finde ich ach ja und im zug kann ich
sagen das war ziemlich scheiße also das
war echt wahr wird mir jetzt ich bin
froh dass ich nicht
ich habe 13 jahre fußball gespielt aber
habe jetzt leider aufgehört
warum im kanal ich habe einfach keinen
bock mehr und fertig aber ich habe halt
wirklich 13 jahren fußball gespielt
seitdem ich dreieinhalb oder vier habe
ich angefangen irgendwie so und ich habe
einen halbbruder also ja halbbruder von
astana vielleicht erklärt wird
irgendwann mal genauer aber halt
halbbruder was auch nicht so viele
wissen seitdem ich zehn bin kann ich
gitarre spielen also ich habe mit zehn
angefangen die tage zu spielen
und okay ich spiele schon länger nicht
mehr geht aber ich könnte man versuchen
gitarre zu spielen moment also ich hab
keine ahnung ob ich so anerkannt moment
vielleicht passt dazu der effekt auch
gut ich hab halt eine normale gitarre
und eine edith hat aber die e gitarren
straßengrün deswegen habe ich mal diese
rausgekramt da wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
nur das problem seien dies total
verstimmt aber wie könnte man testen und
zwar jetzt sogar eine saite gerissen
ich konnte jetzt trotzdem versuchen
irgendwas zu spielen das hier wäre jetzt
zum beispiel ein aber das ist schief und
ja irgendwie man hier so ein vorschlag
dem moment da kann ich besser
ich sollte es unbedingt mal wieder üben
aber ich konnte mich kann auch bietet er
wollte ich esse wirklich sehr sehr sehr
gerne fastfood auch so vielleicht mal
mehrmals die woche und mein lieblings
fast food restaurant ist burger king
also ich bin am meisten herbergen caseys
auch geld aber halt berg ließ auch noch
geiler und das gute dabei ist irgendwie
wertigkeit überhaupt nicht fett ok ich
muss dazu auch sagen ich mache sehr viel
sport das wäre jetzt schon wieder der
nächste akt aber ich werde einfach nicht
wert und ich weiß nicht warum also ich
kann wirklich glaube ich jeden tag fast
zu dessen und würde dabei nicht werden
ich finds geil also tiere sehr gerne rap
ist jetzt egal ob es deutschland ist für
mich auch gerne oder so halt eher
weniger monate das finde ich am geilsten
also geist der musik art musik wurde
niemand
ich zocke wirklich nicht so viel aber
wenn ich dann mal zocken dann halt immer
tiefer der rest ist scheiße also wenn
der fall sonst gar nichts mehr ging es
jetzt zwei wochen total scheiße aber
jetzt geht es mir wieder richtig gut und
deswegen habe ich auch richtig bock
weiter youtube videos zu machen ich habe
ein iphone 5 s und erst haltet euch fest
ich habe sogar whatsapp es hat
eigentlich normal dass heutzutage jeder
whatsapp habt also ich weiß es wirklich
nicht nur weil ich kenne jetzt keinen er
kein rezept hat schreibt man die
kommentare ob das bei euch normal ist
dass jeder mensch für mich mega
interessieren mein lieblingsgetränk ist
cola aber ich trinke auch richtig gerne
diese müller milch und weil ich das
jetzt hier eingreifen habe ich wieder 20
euro mehr verdient das war jetzt
natürlich nur spaß leute also ich kriege
dadurch kein geld ehrlich jetzt
ach ja was dazu auch noch gut passt also
dieses müller milch mag ich wirklich
gerne aber so halt nur mich mag ich
nicht das ist halt in meiner probleme
milch an sichtbar voll eklig mein
lieblings urlaubsland ist spanien
und ich war schon 15 mal in spanien das
heißt seitdem ich zwei bin fliege ich
jedes jahr nach spanien
aber ich kann mich heute an die jahre so
bis neun jahre gar nicht erinnern
blöd ich bin instagram fast genau sogar
im youtube deswegen folgende auf jeden
fall
der link oder der name ist in der video
beschreibung und vielleicht auch hier
einbindet was ich überhaupt nicht
verstehe ist warum ich auf facebook und
twitter jetzt im vergleich zu ich heiße
übrigens auch block wasser
im vergleich zu youtube ist hab ich halt
mega wenig follower und checke ich warum
das so ist deswegen ich bin da auch
aktiv checkt es auf jeden fall ab und
folgt mit einfach blockbuster suchen und
dann folgen ist immer gut bei mir fängt
die schule um acht uhr morgens an und es
reicht irgendwie immer wenn ich um halb
acht auf stehe ich meinen stil auf
frühstücke machen mich fertig war zur
schule 58 los war reicht und dann bin
ich auch schon da und ja eigentlich ganz
gut ich bin wirklich sehr gern auf
partys aber auch nur halt dann wenn sie
gut zu wenig scheiße das ist so kacke
aber ist manchmal so lange aber sonst
wenn ihr kein sind richtig geil wollte
dann jetzt auch der letzte fakt was ich
euch mal sagen wollte ich lese zwar
immer nur diese zahl diese diese
abonnentenzahl zwar ist das krass aber
man merkt wirklich nicht immer auf was
für viele menschen unterschätzen aber
ich habe das in den letzten in der
letzten zeit diese ganzen kommentare die
mir geschrieben habt richtig kasse
dankeschön dafür also man checkt erst in
solchen phasen was für nette menschen
hinter sitze was für einen tollen
charakter ganz viele von euch haben und
dafür wollte mich einfach mal bedanken
und somit mit diesen worten weil ich das
video abschießen ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen weiß ja dass auf jeden fall
noch nach oben da und sonst wäre ich
sagen hier auf der linken seite geht es
weiter mit meinem ex mio das war nochmal
so eine klarstellung zu allen und hier
auf der anderen seite lasst euch
überraschen stück weit ist ab und
abonnieren nicht vergessen wir sind uns
dann im laufe der woche schon wieder
antrete